c'est un équipement flambant neuf
installé depuis trois mois à la gare
sncf de montargis mais cette consigne à
vélo est pour l'instant plutôt vide
on sent un intérêt puisque à chaque fois
qu'on vient on a des questions il ya il
ya des choses qui se passent
mais maintenant je pense qu'il faut
qu'on le fasse davantage connaître parce
que c'était un bel outil qui est à
disposition de la population depuis un
an l'agglomération montargoise s'est
lancé dans la location de vélos
électriques sur les 100 disponible 65
son ouïe signe peut-être de son intérêt
à cette forme de mobilité
mais à force de rouler ce cycliste tombe
sur des situations qu'ils interpellent
alors là le problème de typiquement de
ce panneau c'est que ces partis du
principe de l'art sécurisé l'artère
c'est circuler en centre-ville ici en
faisant passer les cyclistes à pied
plutôt qu'en vélo
sauf que dans les faits c'était
l'accident to them parce que la majorité
des cyclistes prennent la chaussée pour
gagner du temps parce que dans la vie au
quotidien
l'idée c'est d'aller vite également à la
mairie de villemandeur explique qu'elle
ne souhaitait pas avoir une piste
cyclable trop près des entrées des
commerces mais globalement l'association
but love souligne un manque de cohérence
dans les aménagements examen nagement
qui sont faits dans une volonté dans une
envie de bien faire mais ya pas de
cohésion en fait sortir des aménagements
qu'on pourrait avoir à villemandeur ici
ou dans une autre ville de
l'agglomération
donc ça c'est un peu une petite lacune
et au delà de ça il ya un manque
d'anticipation généralement sa part du
principe de vouloir bien faire on fait
des aménagements pour les cyclistes au
final on se rend compte que dans les
faits c'est pas du tout pratique et pas
du tout sécurisé en l'agglomération a
investi énormément de respect surtout
caps et plusieurs milliards d'euros pour
deux attaquants
à la pâte pour les droits les normands
depuis ce système pour se développer au
centre-ville de vous décevoir là on a
une piste cyclable ici on est sur une
piste cyclable
il n'y a pas rien de chez tous des
passais mes gars encore beaucoup à faire
vous savez on peut pas dans un milieu
urbain inventer des pistes cyclables là
où les voit sortir et v9 a rencontré le
candidat lors des élections municipales
pour leur proposer des idées pour
améliorer la cohabitation entre deux
roues voitures et piétons
mais le premier passe d'abord du civisme
et le respect du code de la route